welcome to this video for around six of
the candidates in London and this video
will be a bit shorter just a bit short I
tried tried many times before to make
make them shorter but this is this time
it's simply due to an interesting no
development then I'm going to travel to
London on Saturday to watch three rounds
live at the side and frankly I don't
even have a suitcase I just decided
today to to do that book the flight the
hotel and so on but I need to do some
things to be probably a prepared to to
travel on saturday so i'll do a coverage
of this round but it will be a bit
quicker and hopefully on saturday i will
have some nice on site information
available i'll do a video from the hotel
but not quite sure let's see what what's
possible maybe can do some some video I
don't know it is all very much
spontaneous decision today to do that
alright so let's check the games for
today and start with Ryoga found the
problem on paper least interesting game
because they both on- course and
probably won't win the tournament we
have a Bishop b5 Sicilian girl phantom
for his preparation for the World
Championship match um prepared this
decision with 96 leading to a freshly
caught but we should be five played very
often and here it leads to yeah very
close position where white has got this
bridge had only five which means that
all whites normal direction here will be
towards the king and we see that we
shook sets up a position where he's got
some pieces gets towards the king he
will play even see for later too
to use this bishop a bit but black has
got very nicely centralized pieces or he
certainly has got nothing to fear this
prepare our c4 and here it comes white
of course needs this Bishop on a one if
he wouldn't have played see for himself
there's the danger that black might
place before I'd kill this Bishop so on
good continued wide put some pieces and
the vicinity of the king but black has
got a nice confirmation on the queenside
and he's got two against one pound so
this is typically a nice asset for black
and where white has got this possible
attacking chances however just a couple
of moves later we see here that down a
girlfriend is attacking the e5 pawn it
cannot easily be taken of course if the
spawn is gone then this long agonal
really gets against Ricky even a Greek
now plays Knight to d6 which at first
side looks very attractive entering with
the night maybe go here or maybe allow
some some some sacrifices evening well
on a very good day you can sacrifice on
f7 but the problem with this move is it
looks it looks good but it has a
technical drawback girlfriend simply
took the poor now and this is slightly
embarrassing that the point is after 95
there's this trick and maybe this is
what we shook underestimated or
miscalculated in this line now the queen
is saying and the night design this is
so of course not on because maeda
threatened but this this move Knight f6
is simply strong and at the end of all
this
like has one upon and has got a clear
advantage it's got those two bishops and
very strong positions and look at this
we have won the shipment simply
ridiculous please so black has a very
clear advantage and if you look continue
some moves now even this Bishop is
basically dead you simply expect
girlfriend to win this game is much
ahead on the clock Eden and extra porn
and everything is great I mean I mean if
I had black I would expect to win
against greece shook even because it
looks simply overwhelming but it's still
a bit tricky we'll see you up to what
happens rook to e8 this is good checking
am covering v5 and okay the last
reserves so to say f6 a good move would
be one Queen f7 so this is all fine yeah
now f5 this simply m is the last the
last try white wants to swing over the
rope here or here and then maybe try to
get at age six those bishops are a bit
away from the from the Kings side but
it's not really add a serious attack so
let's see what happens so exactly as
described this Bishop is going for for
the h6 bone the thing is is there threat
and the answer is no girl phantom here
could have simply taken on a two and and
basically that's it there's there's no
attack coming y term cannot sacrifice if
you look at this this is maybe the move
that you fear with Bishop h6 black can
go oops look 2 h8 and now bishop age 6
very simple simply bad you don't lose
this instantly but why doesn't a self
pin and he has has no moves basically so
rather rather easy win and I really
don't see what white is doing he may be
thought he would win anyway but um
without taking here by now this was two
minutes against two minutes somehow
Gavin's weren't quite some time before
he had a big time advantage he played
this movie it still keeps the advantage
but Luke a to probably would have would
have killed this now this is at least
covered for the moment he he played a
somewhat passive setup which somehow
should be enough but the other thing was
winning outright yeah efore difficult to
play was just a couple of seconds on the
clock and queen age form this is the
their DM like Tucker and Bishop h5 now
yeah this is all all good
yeah route d3 and we can still have a
look black ass still a porn up and why
just got some weak pawns and not the
greatest King so still this should be am
quite an advantage for me for girlfriend
but let's see 25 Queen g4 here's some
playing and yeah she's committing a
mistake now with hindsight you you see
that instead of this he could have
played Bishop b6 activating this piece
and simply ignoring this this g six
square there is no thread white can give
this check for example but he doesn't
really have a continuation hear that
that travels like let's say Queen h5
just for argument's sake there's there's
a move like this taking see for taking
the rook and white has no a decent
answer to that cannot go here for
example as this is of course the main
issue
yeah the problem is simply what he did
is not enough he played he played Bishop
e8 and now this Bishop g6 coming have a
look at this now white is really active
and he's got those sacrifice ideas on h
sticks black basically doesn't have any
other moves and moving this bishop and
now there's Bishop Bishop h6 and it's by
now clear that white has very good
counter play and in fact them they
agreed the draw shortly afterwards
because girlfriend now gave her these
chicks and it's basically / peppered
perpetual white cannot get out of this
so I'm Gahan had a real big chance here
to to win the game and yeah somewhat
said you really outplayed grew shocked
but simply around here he played not
courageous enough group takes a two
seems to seems to win he for some reason
now I didn't want to play this move
usually there's some some some concrete
miscalculation involved but this
probably would have would have won this
game ok so so the next game let's have a
look at your job off against Aronian we
have from rue Lopez our own young is
very consistent he place on five all the
time sometimes he plays stuff like d6 or
g6 some against weaker weaker opponents
like 2006 hundreds in the bundesliga in
Germany but it doesn't happen against
those top guys he pays in five all the
time okay we've got a Berlin with d3 and
c3 we saw this before in the same game
of Carlton with white again screw
shook it is slightly different because
our job of doesn't take on c6 which
after those moves leads to a pretty
standard rule of pest position which
easily could have been on the board from
a different mood water with the neural
ea-6b five line this so-called only it
has got a ton of names neo Arkhangelsk
or two cats EF variation with a 6b five
and Bishop c5 um okay it's a d3 c3 set
up so it's always this kind of slow
maneuvering game have a couple of
exchanges and Aronian managed to play d5
and this is really a rule of thumb when
all kinds of a 45 position and black
matches to play d5 and white cannot
punish this immediately then black is
equalized and this is I think the KCM
it's I don't really see what what why
does aspiring to in this position it's
simply am it simply around equal what
white can try to do is to put something
on a 5 and this is what you say is doing
something means night of course this is
basically the only idea that white has
in this position and frankly speaking
that's not much I must say that I'm a
little bit of bias in these positions
because I play if I was black against
you for four years and I always ask
myself well what the hell is why doing
here isn't it like nothing and yeah this
is simply my way of seeing this position
I don't think that wider has got even
the slightest hint of anything because I
will look at this I mean all pieces are
fine and why the only has got this this
little little bit of something on f on
f5 okay
continued with all this and now is g5 at
at first looks looks a bit scary we've
got those nights here but there's no
real attack simply because the queen is
not involved and you cannot really a
meet black or get serious attack without
the Queen he tries to use the g file
here but take into account that black
has the slightly better structure he's
got this porn island and this well white
has this double porn which is not a big
issue at the moment of course but it can
be later and he's got slightly
compromised on strategy on the King side
so black is probably slightly more
comfortable but it's not much they when
Carlton was in the in the commentators
room and he was asked about this
position any thought okay yeah live only
slightly better so what he said okay and
that continued for a while and yeah
quite funny discovery here but black can
simply cover it note that read
Jonathan's lil bit of charm trouble but
he managed to make make the required
moves in time frankly there is not so
much happening black still enjoys the
slightly better structure this rook and
night always attack before but it
doesn't really look like like much
however it down of course continued
Aronian played on he easily it doesn't
risk much in this position
and we see that your job of again has
got time problems he used lots of time
yeah we're nearing the critical position
so i will look at this what is black
doing is attacking this pawn and yeah
now Queenie one trying to exchange the
Queen yeah of course if black now takes
only four it gets very embarrassing so
of course this didn't happen he just
went to to a forum and now night xe5
rajabhat was down to what let's check it
one minute 25 I it's not really
comfortable eight moves in one and a
half minute yeah this is some really the
clock plays a very important role in
this tournament the the time management
yeah 95 the problem is for Queen takes
and what now this night is saying and
why it cannot move the king I mean where
let's say here just grab it and today as
the King go and have six covering the
Queen and yeah this is just maturity it
down for for nothing you can you can try
to continue this line like this but this
is a disaster the spawn gets gets lost
and then black simply wins in the end
game so what did the job of do he
retreated the night night air form and
resigns so the very sudden end to this
which is really also due to the fact
that John was spent really lots of time
in this position the thing is that
simply are also uncomfortable to play
you're sort of uncoordinated with with
your with your loose pawns and all those
weaknesses so it's clear that black is
slightly better at least but the time
management really killed him in this
game so aronian another win with black
and very important step in this
tournament plus three already is quite
something ok let's look at swidler cards
next swidler with plus one good
tournament he bought a very good
position yesterday against girlfriend
and Carlton yeah well we know he's in a
very comfortable shape plus two and now
let's see what happens again the room
cousin own place md5 most of the times
against 1.e4 and now here he is going
for the classical main line not the
Berlin this time this will replace d3
which is one of those countless anti
marshal lines on the traditional main
line of course rupee one and now this is
the marshal idea with d5 and in fact
Carlin doesn't really play the marshal
he usually goes form form the brier one
of those big main lines of the ruin ok
but swidler went for d3 which is one of
those as mentioned d 3 C 3 and so on
lines a form yeah here a bit
surprisingly maybe Carston went for
before not that it is bad move with it
is not of course but one point of this
move all of like this DC
and so on to play Bishop deserve this is
the move I play myself in this position
so I'm I was slightly surprised to see
before played it's a it's not a big big
thing before it's fine but this is what
is what is normally a mom normally
played before yeah it for at first it
looks a bit strange because you give
away the square so wide can play
maneuvers like this but it's really not
that important we see what happens in
the game it's all very very logical we
should be 60 I very often you want to
put the bishop their exchange it on b3
but why prevents it with 94 would be
eight now nc3 yeah y term place III
intending in the long run to play
default it is in general a bit difficult
to to give from the white game to give
it some some sort of point and because
well you're not putting much pressure on
black with this pawn chain here this is
why when c3 to get some play in the
center of course you can play all kinds
of slow setups like a rookie one or
something but ok this was Willis point
and now h6 very normal 95 can be
annoying so you go age 60 k 1 and Quincy
a this is also a good maneuver and known
maneuver it allows Luke the eighth with
d5 coming maybe and gets out of the
default well maybe sometime sometimes
the white rook might appear so it's a
it's a good multi-purpose move Bishop c2
yeah here at first sight you you would
think that this maybe is an idea but
cousin I didn't go for that the problem
with this is it looks good for at first
because it's an isolated double bond for
white but how does like a tacit it's not
easy
you don't actually have a single piece
that can I take this disc on and you
weaken the light squares enormously
white is got this ideas I don't think
this is really a good option to take
cards now went for something else he
played rook da bridges I think just
better intending d5 Queenie to you
should be fate it's better on a fate
simply compared to you 793 and now g5 so
as mentioned already in the Ronin game
if if black manages to play d5 and he's
not punished for that he's normally okay
and this is I think the case here as
well black certainly should have
equalised and the way it progress now
black even has a little bit more than
equality I'm probably litem should have
played something else here before yeah
of course 93 is not the only move what's
clear is if you if you look at this
we've got those exchanges h3 now it's
bit of a prophylactic move Bishop g4
versa was a bit dumb a bit of a problem
yeah the question is what what else
should why do maybe you can consider a
tactical sequences am like a bishop to a
form or default maybe default let's say
it takes and this one going going from
eight g6 we should be four yeah some
technical line to to keep the the
position around equal once black has
played this this d5 it's simply that
white needs to get be be cautious i mean
a fiber saying this route p.m.
it's not done it's not very comfortable
already okay he went for age three
Bishop f5 and Ruby one slightly passive
but yeah what can you do Queenie six and
this is in a way a typical Carlton game
he puts his pieces in the center are in
good positions and somehow the other
side just goes down I mean it's really
really amazing how quickly the sometimes
is happening Swilley are now plays we
should be one go into the seven
attacking the porn we should be three
and before it's all very logical it's
not difficult we need to sometimes yes
see the move that is playing but it all
works so nicely together yeah white now
place not to deform what can you do
cannot capture here the loop was the
problem so 94 Knight takes and yeah in
this position on she takes deep voice
the alternative and maybe the better
move we are from let's say mathematical
perspective as this is not instantly
losing but it's really a really ugly
position look at this I mean this is
just great for black and he's got the
host ropes are taking the form you have
Bishop d6 covering your only slight
weakness and white is got rather bad
structure against such a brilliant
technical players cards this is just a
torture this is things simply Weiss
Villa went here then the fun point is
here cars and just just took on d3 and
here there was also a computer
possibility the sacrifice this is really
working amazingly the point is takes
g5g three yeah that was saying here and
now okay f3 and at this point you may be
stopped with your calculation because
well what is this Bishop doing if you
want if you retreat let's say here then
it's not clear what is happening
something like this is even playable
maybe it's not not an outright win but
what black can do is he has got this
this hammer blow here at the group big
do Queen takes just a roof sec here and
this is in fact winning there's this
fret and Queen 83 and it's not
defensible simply a win as also this is
hain yeah okay Calvin didn't do that and
in the press conference when they asked
both players it seems they didn't really
consider this but what Calvin saw is as
usual it's simple and good he took on d3
exchanged here and played c5 at first
you think oh wait this is winning a
piece right it's not white has got this
little trick and this is what does
really hoped for but I have a look at
this I think exactly this position is
and what cars are sawing probably m
capital moves ahead of course but if you
look at this you simply recognize that
black is just much better it's got the
active rook this is a weakness this is a
weakness and actually they can be
attacked black spawns cannot so easily
be attacked and black has got rooked e
to Bishop c5 while this is a little bit
of a stranded piece on PA tande the rook
is not playing on a one so it's not
great and a couple of moves later
here and Sue Ellen outright for
something that the spit that really is
not working but he certainly was pretty
much disgusted with his position already
and he's down to seven minutes he played
Queen to h5 and while this at least has
got a threat and let's say black does
nothing much here what can you do let's
say you would play whoop Dee to here and
you can treat this as a puzzle white why
to win and in fact there there are two
ways to do so you want you can pause the
video the fleshy way to do it is this
move with a mate I think I would do that
give think you in the chance but there's
also this mate which is even quicker but
not so nice so there are some tricks now
but cards invested a couple of minutes
and came up with Queenie for simple and
good this of course prevents Queen f5
and it also prevents this idea because
of Queen age 7 and that's it I mean
white can snatch the spawn but now is
out of bullets nothing to do just an
extra recruit black and an easy win so
this prevents all kinds of checks and
trickery and at the end what is there
yeah lots of problems if let's say white
plays some moves let's say rookie area
just for for example to show the threat
then blacks can simply take here this
will mate white
and this is the big the big threat yet
what has simply no way to address this
besides the move that you played he
played rugby to covering up to but now
there's rope d5 covering the bishop
pinning the bishop and young white has
no real way to to cover that he can go
rookie to which you did quinby one check
King edge to f6 and that's it this
Bishop is gone is it just a simple game
we all can play like him right yeah it's
sometimes amazing from out of nothing
that's a good position out of the
opening and then it goes simply downhill
so quickly against the best players of
the world it's hard to explain sometimes
and frankly I didn't I didn't have the
time to analyze in detail while swidler
went wrong here because this is
certainly am comfortable for black but
you shouldn't be winning in in like 60
moves after that yeah very important win
for cards and obviously plus 3 and this
is done with for blacks and I yet for
blacks up to now so very very good
position in the tournament okay last
game is chrome Nick even shook and as
usual my idea to make a shorter video
fail miserably already on 31 minutes or
32 minutes yeah well kinda give a shock
especially if you now take into account
that cardinal de ronnian one again so
they r plus free leading with four and a
half points from Nick who only played
draws up to now needs to win I mean
everything else is not acceptable in
this game um and it's not that he's
playing badly actually he played I think
a really good game against erroneous and
was so close to winning but it didn't it
didn't manage it doesn't help if you if
you play a play great but you don't
score goals so the same okay um we have
a Catalan here a rare line with what
to check on before and not rare as this
move which would be six Bishop e7 has
been played yeah thousands of times we
should be success only caught on
recently the idea is to set up exactly
as a bunch of dgn this way a little bit
like em in the semi Slav intending to
play you five at some point or capture
and then in five yeah the problem is a
bit for white now in this position what
what are you doing about this pawn on c4
you don't have a natural move to cover
it as the bishop is somewhat in the way
on d to if the bishop would be still on
c1 there will be moved like night to d2
and d4 but the bishop is on D 2 and this
is why black inserted this check this
Bishop is not really a well placed on
YouTube yeah kramnik decided on an
aggressive approach he just sacrificed
this ball and a black I think also needs
to take now if you play some normal move
let's say queen here Bessie for and with
this threat we get this transformation
in the center where white has a very
convenient advantage quite quite some
extra space good pieces and they're so
this very bad bishop on c8 this is why
black wants to play your 5 of course get
this Bishop into play this means that
normal moves don't do it like mistake so
he took on c4 and now look you won this
is good 51 um it's designed to work
against a five if black na would go we
five which is the plant move of course
it looks a quite suspicious at first and
it is suspicious if black can faces this
now 95 in fact loses to Bishop f4 this
is simply a deadly pen
and this also doesn't help leading to a
win from white just two pieces for the
rook and a brilliant brilliant position
at all pieces of fine so if I've is not
on black must prepare this he played
Queen to c7 to prepare be five and get
the Queen out of the D file an
alternative here was the sharp moved be
five but this is very risky one point
being night g5 attacking this pawn and
this spawn I mean I'm threatening to
take on b5 because there's the pin if
black now plays Queen B 6 this is an
interesting line that I'd like to show
White has a very strong continuation
here the mood be three this is the point
here white has sacrificed upon but he's
got excellent compensation one point for
example is if black in our place the
very normal looking move Bishop d7
that's this coming yeah threatening on
age 7 and this is not all of it there's
also this strict look at blacks Queen
let's get it gets embarrassing now Queen
needs to go to a 6 and this simply picks
up the Queen for a couple of pieces but
why it still has the attack going even
so it's it's a complete disaster b5 is
simply too risky in this position
evangel played much better Quincy seven
in fact I think this is an excellent
game both sides played played really
well here okay NAT G intending hmmm
something to afford to pick up the pawn
on c4 and you want to play Bishop e7
getting out of this 94 with the tempo a
form and e5 this was the idea Black has
played or for this advanced all the time
to get the c8 Bishop into play
in a chronic place a5 is very very
interesting concept he simply lets this
pawn yeah on pre-black can take it and
simply black gum doesn't really have fun
anything else he took it on before and
now Bishop f4 this was the whole point
the checking the Queen and done yeah
this looks looks really really bad so
black must go Bishop t6 and now ready
for this was the whole point of this a
5m IDM white has got the active rook now
on the fourth rank and now I think if
one should place them in the most
principled way and the best way if you
are now as black um simply give give
away you'll see for porn that you want
then then you're worse this is it's as
simple as that if you play some some
nothing move now let's say I don't know
let's say a 60m why it just takes here
and place place this can of game on the
queenside Spader later maybe efore f4 it
just it just not nice eventual played
much better he played h6 night back and
b5 simply the principled way keep the
porn and Dwight now must take also on b6
that's nothing else 94 black can play a
six and you will turn the porn something
like this year needs to nothing I would
even start to prefer black here you've
got your pieces all out and you've got
two against one I guess this one not be
one so why do I takes this is better
you'd need to damage the pawn structure
and night to be six yeah it here in this
position I'm white can consider other
moves than the one that chrome neck
plate but chronic went for the exchange
fries and this is simply it's the most
obvious move into position and it's
probably also may be the best it the
thing is it's not clear what this rook
is doing on the fourth-ranked if you
cannot sacrifice it on f6 white can play
let's say here but look at this where's
this route going and it can go to h4 but
what exactly is it is doing on edge for
is not clear so it's really a moot point
white white meets the second is just a
lot so just just the right move okay it
takes and 94 centralizing the night and
whites compensation is simply based on
the fact that black has no pawn
structure now it's just lots of split
pawns isolated pawns and lots of
weaknesses so on I think it's really
easy to see that white has a great
compensation the question is is it
enough a bunch of plate Bishop Basabe
which is the best move it covers c6 and
now Kramnik goes Queen d2 which is okay
he had alternatives though the most
important being Luke a file and I think
maybe this was the the better practical
digs decision due to the fact that you
won shook as as we know by now is
notoriously always in time travel is
down to 10 minutes for 20 moves and I
think rue k5 would have been the the
more yeah maybe maybe a trickier to play
with with a little time there are some
obvious relatively obvious points if
black for instance plays Knight to g5
white as can go here and now black is
not able to take on a 5 I mean you can
but it's not not ending ending nicely
and that's unavoidable made now quite
nice the squeegee Queens v6 idea always
need to take that into account okay this
is the easy line what black can however
can do is he needs to use this route
p.m. and rook aid is a strong move
intending rookie 5 I think this is easy
to see for a player of your bunch of
class but right now can play all kinds
of attacking ideas which are dangerous
you can go Brooke edge 5 for instance
King g7 and now Bishop c6 this is one
possibility black now it cannot take
this is this now leads to checkmate
very cute line and it's completely
forced it's a mate yeah and white has a
really good attack IAM the thing is and
this is the important difference to the
game but of course it's super difficult
to to to assess this white can hear yeah
he can attack um without being forced to
go for a perpetual or somehow um he
hasn't burned all his bridges in this
position you can play on this position
without being under such huge pressure
to get something completely in a very
short order in in the game you will see
the difference that Queen d2 King g7 and
now he took 16 which after takes to
check king now white is a whole rock
down and he needs to justify that and
this is in fact the best rest babe let's
play by both sides so it's really am
really fine with what they played now
here it's a look down and white didn't
have much of a choice year instead of
taking you you can still consider UK
five but in comparison the meteor gave
five would have been would have been
better of course okay takes have a look
at this and one point is of course I'm
from practical point of view what
prominent it yet he's got a draw in the
back white can draw here with the night
h4 check King back and it's a perpetual
black needs to go here and we can repeat
moves of course Kramnik didn't want to
do that in fact here there's Queen takes
h6 as a possibility this kind of stuff
but after King g6 um why it needs to
frost the perpetual again the
nothing else so is it a draw well the
draw is not enough for chronic he played
Luke a five and this is risky but ok a
draw won't do so he he continued with
the rook down I'm still attacking but
he's got much more time of course Queen
default with oops this idea made on g7
so rook g8 or frost and rook c5 and you
Roxie fight was just activating this
peace pudding this Bishop in a pin so
moves like 94 are on the agenda and the
eventual played played greater with four
minutes on the clock 27 s it's just good
attacking the king at the Queen so needs
to react to a form and now h5 covering
the g four square and this is the
critical position now Kramnik now spent
almost all of his time trying to find
something and he simply he didn't find a
way to continue this attack it's simply
a rope down this is a problem you cannot
really a play em some some slow moves
that strengthens your position and you
don't have the time for that with the
rook down let's say f three years was a
suggestion and from the commentators
then there's rupee eight I mean now
rookie six or rupee five our defensive
ideas it's not enough a rookie sarouk so
at the end chronic settle for this check
and he gave those checks to to to make a
perpetual and in fact here if you look
at the clock is here evangel guess given
where the minute he had a blue bit more
time not much a little bit more um in
fact here even shook could have played
the king of eight it's not losing
it's only like so look at this it's a
logical continuation it's a yeah it's a
position where blacks king is dodging
bullets all the time it's like walking
into a crossfire Queen night look it's
it's simply a super risky I mean those
rooks are not helping at the moment um
the computer likes black it gives black
an advantage of let's say a porn or
slightly more but look at this it's a
rookie I'm so white has excellent
compensation for this it's a especially
in a practical game the big thing is
Yvonne ship was on slightly more than a
minute and he would have never been able
to defend this position and in this time
simply not possible so he he simply
agreed to this perpetual and and I made
a draw so I'm a very yeah disappointing
end for for chronic I think he played a
great game I mean what what can you say
he tried everything that there is with
an exchange second it was a bit unlucky
in a way that he had no no way at all to
continue I think he he would have risked
quite a lot to to try to to continue
here because he was aware that a draw is
not enough but okay he needed to to take
the draw at the end it's also no use to
lose of course if you if it would have
lost the game it's simply over for this
tournament you cannot come back from
minus one catching someone two points
ahead so okay after this round we have
carbon and Aronian leading with three
wins no losses great result they are
both too close to 3000 performance
rating and they are leading with one and
a half points ahead of Kramnik and
swidler
both have fifty percent so what you can
already argue that kramnik auto union
will make it it's it's it's very
difficult to to see a scenario where
Kramnik us will die would catch them
everybody else is completely out of it
from minus score you cannot cannot come
back it's not possible yeah it will be
very important to see if the first
couple of games now the next two three
rounds and if front against will they
are not managing to win then one of
those rollin and Carlton would make it
it's also the may be the most them the
yeah i think if you think about it what
kind of what championship match do you
want to see you really want to see him I
don't know we should playing or someone
I mean really everything else besides
Carlton and Aronian would seem a bit
strange kramnik of course I've always
been a fan of this play but he's been
he's got mean yet the title for a couple
of years and he lost this match against
Ireland a couple of years ago so nobody
i think would mind a car's not romia now
would get get a match that would be very
interesting to watch so let's see what
happens okay I'll be back on saturday
hopefully from from some hotel in London
and maybe I even have some some video
coverage of the event Lisa some pictures
I'm not quite sure it's it's not really
planned I mean a couple of hours ago I
didn't even know I would go so let's see
I hope it all works out fine okay so
i'll be back on yeah saturday till then
bye